oh i discovered a really cool
opening trap on twitter the other day so
there's this twitter person also a chess
master dad a scientist
i should follow he tweeted
a really cool
position which i had never seen before
this insane position occurred 116 times
in leeches database which makes more
sense when you realize it follows one of
i am rosen's opening traps
and when i initially saw this tweet i
didn't realize
what exactly
the line was and then i had to recreate
it so i want to share
this opening trap which for those
watching you should never try
but it's really really cool but the
reason why you should never try it is
because
you do it as white it requires you to
fall into an opening trap to begin with
and it starts in this dumb gambit line
which i made a whole video about
where you go into the sign
white takes and then 97. yeah though the
whole video is on youtube but the basic
point is that white should not take the
knight
because then white loses the queen after
takes takes and takes
and if we look at the stats here
wow there's 25 000
games
when i make the video real quick tangent
so the crazy thing about the stats here
when i initially made this video there
were about 420 games
in the variation on me chess but now
there's over 25 000 people falling for
the trap
r.i.p to the 36 people who took the
queen
first oh it's kind of funny but anyway
so the opening trap it happens when
white goes into this line
and gives away a queen
and this is known to just be winning for
black blacks up a queen but there's a
really funny line which happens after
knight c3
black takes on c2
knight d4
and we'll just follow the most common
moves queen
g6 and now knight t5 and
yeah white gets some interesting
initiative
holds on to the e7 pawn most played move
is knight a6 which i think is the best
move
but the second most played move is queen
d6
and here we see the position that
matches
the tweet and this is white to move
and win
and there's no reason to ever try to
enter this position
but
the winning move is pretty incredible
for white
so i'll leave it up to chat oh 41 matt
saying bishop f4 bishop f4 would sadly
lose a knight
but there's a better way to lose a
knight
is knight b5 and now the queen's hit
and if queen takes night light wins back
the queen
and it swipes up a piece here
and the funny thing about this move is
white is sacking either knight because
black also has this move
and after a bishop e3 whichever knight
is taken the other knight will come to
c7 and fork the king
and the queen
so it's just some really beautiful
geometry
and if we look in the database
almost no one finds it 111 games white
played e4
nine people found this
and white wins like almost all of them
yeah queen c5 vision e3 and
yeah the problem for black
even if the queen doesn't take either
knight and moves to like c6
then we can see
yeah there's a few ways to win engine
gives takes king d7 rook d1
and the compensation is just
overwhelming
oh there's a funny line
wait a minute so let's say black just
waits a move
knight b6
takes and then mate
knight goes into the corner with mates
unfortunately there's king e7 here
but it's still somehow winning
yeah this is just such a such a fun
position with the rook both knights upon
an
e7 uh so it goes to show that
some people can as black and trick white
but then
very quickly get into a losing position
i might put this on youtube as just like
a quick
opening trap video i want to title this
video
the coolest opening trap you should
never try